just like her music video Mexican pop
star Sofia Reyes is bold bright and
breaking through I have faith that I'm
gonna be a huge star and that the whole
world is gonna know who I am
not only is sofia one of the biggest
names in Latin music she's also a proud
Latina woman
cementing her name in an industry
dominated by men okay this time okay but
at the end alarum en la ley at just 23
years old Sofia has nearly nine million
monthly spotify listeners a Best New
Artist Latin Grammy nomination and over
three hundred million views on her
latest music video a topic that guts
Sophia choked up when I stopped by her
Los Angeles home first sit-down
interview why am I so sentimental this
is my life as a Latina we're here in
your home we want to get to know the
real Sofia I love it I want to start at
the beginning yeah you're a little girl
growing up in Monterrey Mexico yes what
was your first memory of I think I want
to be a singer I was too kind of girl
that you know my mom wanted to go
shopping or whatever I would be like
dancing and wearing all the clothes in
front of the mirror and like they're
always very dramatic yeah I like intense
and I love performing and I believed
that I was the star when I was little
I mean I was always surrounded by music
playing piano for me is like it gives me
freedom it's like my moment and if it
makes me feel powerful because when I
worked so hard in the song and then when
I actually know how to play it it feels
so good that you're not even thinking
and your fingers are moving and your
meat making music I don't know it's
really it's beautiful
and took singing classes acting classes
modeling classes and I loved all that
anything that had to do with art I loved
it sounds like your parents were very
supportive of their being in the arts I
owe everything to my parents they pushed
me to you know pursue my dreams would
you be where you are today without them
no I don't think so we have a little
surprise for you ah what is it some
there's someone who's very proud of you
I know all that's you that was we are so
proud of you not just because you're a
big star but you're a great human being
will not you I was not expecting this I
know English what's going through your
mind I love my dad and I'm also like
really sentimental and I miss them
obviously so when it comes to my family
I always get really like sentimental
they've been really good parents so I
feel like I want to make them out I
think you're doing a great so that's
good yeah thank you so I was 15 when I
moved to what I found out I was in this
girl group I mean they all became like
friends and actually like sisters family
um but he was said it was definitely an
experience I didn't like the team at all
so the management was was not the way
that you wanted to know trace so all of
us the music I was doing was not my
style they would make us compete with
ourselves and at the end of the day like
fight with each other and you know it
was it was it was not a good environment
I was feeling kind of like I'm not gonna
say depressed but I was kind of like I
didn't like what I was going through my
felt really lonely I didn't like what I
was doing and it got to a point where I
was like I don't want to do this thing
you know I just I just don't want to do
this I don't like it and then I go back
to Monterey right and and during the
girl band thing
I meet Charlie and Paloma they're our
best couple ever in there my managers
they wanted to move to LA through music
and everything and my family night felt
like that was the best opportunity you
know like that we had to take that
chance and just go to LA charlie Paloma
tell me that when they met me they like
I was a completely different person
my world was upside down you were
described don't wanna know anything
about music whatever and it took me like
a year to like that's it
everything is faith like I have faith
that I'm gonna be a huge star and that
the whole world is gonna know who I am
and that I'm gonna touch people with my
music what up that's faith a lot of your
success in the early days came from
YouTube yeah what made you open your
laptop one day and say you know what I
think I'm gonna sing covers we're gonna
start from scratch in LA do covers in
English do covers in Spanish I knew how
YouTube was getting very like famous and
how people we're getting you know known
by their music or by their talent you
know through YouTube would open a
Twitter we open it an Instagram a
Facebook account like we planned
everything little by little people got
to know me more and more one of the
covers I got really popular was this
song where Bailey Aquino spasso
you're browsing YouTube covers like
about a year later yeah
capture the attention of a superstar
like Prince Royce I met Prince Royce on
an award show he really liked my covers
that's basically how it started and we
got into the studio wrote a couple songs
and partnered up with Warner Latin
everything happened really fast I wrote
a song called solo yo and I knew that
that was the song I wanted to do with
Royce
[Music]
working with him what does he mean to
you and how has he really elevated your
career as a singer he taught me so much
he having like writing sessions with him
taught me to be a better songwriter he's
an amazing performer so you've studied
him for sure for sure what's the best
piece of advice is given you having fun
is the key if you have fun everyone's
gonna have fun we got really involved
that was like four years ago to the
project and yeah and here we are and
here we are
[Music]
the album was a huge success thanks so
much so that you got nominated for Best
New Artist at the 2017 Latin Grammys
yeah was that unbelievable my boyfriend
he's also see her and he was nominated
as well
you were announced each other like that
the whole thing was really funny
he calls me right he calls me it was
like 7 a.m. here and he felt so he was
so nervous
he's like I'm nominated but maybe my
girlfriend isn't and I don't know how to
feel about it yeah you know and I was
the last one mention like Sofia Reyes
and you're so excited so no bo z Ricky
no Bennett it feels like you guys are
madly in love and you're so supportive
of one another yeah what has his support
meant to you through this crazy journey
of music oh wow everything I mean that's
why I fell in love with him this life is
not an easy one I feel like you know I
have to travel a lot and then come back
and then maybe I'm here for one day and
then and he does the same so we
understand each other and I don't know
if anyone could like support that you
know what are the qualities about him
that you love the most
he's really funny he's a gentleman he is
like he respects me and he admires me
and he's super talented and he's a good
person like he means well so for me
that's like top everything is perfect
he's marriage a goal for you down the
line it's always been and Ricky and I
are taking a very chilled there's no
rush but like we're just enjoying the
process and we were really happy he's
the one for you yeah for sure I think so
yeah he sounds like a really special guy
yeah yes I take it back I know he's a
special guy because he wanted to send
you a little message hey baby
three key here from what I had a Mexico
I love you I am so proud of you
everything you've accomplished
everywhere where this song has taken you
I'm so proud couldn't be prouder I am so
excited for what's next I always look
forward to everything you're gonna do
artistically and as a person I love you
I'm so proud of you and I can't wait to
see you the day after tomorrow what
makes you emotional I mean he's so sweet
and he's the best and I was not you know
expecting this so definitely a surprise
but he's always like that what's the
most romantic thing he's done for you I
was flying from Argentina
I guess and then I was going all the way
to LA and I there's no direct flight so
I stopped in in Miami and I was just
gonna be there in Miami for like five
minutes cuz I had to run to my next gate
and he bought a ticket he was waiting
for me in the plane in Miami like coming
out of the plane I saw him for five
minutes we walked together to the gate
and then I left to the next play I feel
really proud of myself I feel really
proud of my team because we've worked so
hard for so long it feels good to see
what's going on with him those two days
this has definitely been like a new
experience for me I've never you know
lived what I'm living right now
and I I'm enjoying every second of it
[Music]
my three biggest career goals are Korean
all around the world selling out
stadiums and collaborated with with Ed
Sheeran
hey yeah cheering we could do something
really cool how do you feel being one of
very few powerful young women in music
right now
whoa creo que mucho mucho talento
femenino Latino and then mundo pero hace
falta a poder low-mass Rosalia Ricky G
Carol Gina T Natasha
yo Lally
I need those I'm muchisimas i'ma muchos
ok que todos ustedes NT un golpe muy
fuerte como everett a las mujeres
estamos como que party end oléron pn doe
like eva our chose eve todo sara hombres
y una mujer de que canta y cosas como
que pero por que están todo lo que no se
a feta especial Mantella musica latina
an industrial amo scarlatina porque yo
Tara Penta so to Vezina Beyonce basil
Maria Novella Taylor Swift or no Selena
Gomez when Ariana Grande you'll see all
this powerful woman and you're like in
the lighting industry why don't we have
that would you say there's a sisterhood
amongst you amongst you and Leslie and
Becky G and Carol G for sure all
fighting together yeah make women more
elevated more prominent totally and I
love it and I love that we're all
friends that we all support each other I
don't feel like competition at all it's
never like it's always like hey I'm I'm
here to support you I'm here to and sad
tales it ok so hello my cool cat
Krakatoa somos como team players e you
know sighs Ramos you know Sequoia Mo's I
shall go by the regime au pair au Prince
K to la vez con los hombres Osaka repent
a moon maloom on P 71 on J Balvin unique
Idi Amin Dada Yankee you know soon
tomando say Kunta ya se como que remixes
yah senthil cancion entonces son amigos
y hace ahora esto y con las mujeres de
sono Stanco Montone say céntimos que que
hacemos poultice a booger yo no Tammy a
con todas to skate que decir que me see
this and see yo sock on mujeres por que
creo que era momento des des un rato
crocker an important text emissary para
apoyar knows as an artist yeah how do
you want to be remembered I want to be
remembered someone that you know change
the world in a positive way that you
know inspired people to follow their
dreams and also to inspire people to do
good to love others I hope my music like
once I'm not here in the world anymore I
feel like I want my music to keep like
you know transcending yeah I'm being
played and I want people to still enjoy
my
[Music]
you